welcome everyone
this is Rob Sanders with simply learned
and welcome today we're gonna talk about
email marketing tutorial so buckle up
and let's get started with email
marketing tutorial and so let's start
out asking the question why email
marketing so Linda is the owner of an
e-commerce company and basically she
isn't able to take Hurley's lead she's
collecting per day per month and convert
them into customers
okay so customers sign up but they don't
buy her product so she's left scratching
her head wondering what to do so how's
she gonna solve the problem of
converting the lead she gets into paying
customers
well look no further than email mark so
you can boost your sales funnel with the
help of email marketing so email
marketing leads to email campaigns that
lead to website visits that can lead to
product purchasing email markings also
and a it's a very good way to generate a
high return on investment so Linda
thinks this is too good to be true
you're telling me it's a very efficient
way to generate a return on my
investment
how expensive is email marketing well
email marketing is neither expensive or
time-consuming that's the beauty of
email marketing and so Linda is now very
interested we've piqued her interest she
wants us to explain email marketing to
her in detail and that's exactly what
we're going to do we're going to talk
about email marketing in detail so for
everyone out there listening what's in
it for you why are you going to invest
your time and listening to simply learn
and me talk about me email marketing
because we're gonna talk about
everything there is about email
marketing in today's webinar so what is
it for those that aren't really familiar
with the intricacies of email marketing
we're gonna talk about how to set up
email marketing we're gonna discuss all
the benefits of email marketing we're
gonna get into AV testing we're gonna
get into the automation of emails the
types of emails how to engage new users
and we're gonna give you a demo so
there's a lot going on in this webinar
like I said buckle up and let's get
started and talk about what is email
marketing so as I mentioned to Linda
it's an efficient way to convert leads
into sales why because we can send
personalized emails to a specific
audience a targeted audience if
somebody's interested in our products we
can reach out to them via email it can
also be used to remarket pre-qualified
leads so anybody who's pre-qualified we
can go ahead and communicate with them
as well so email markings are very
effective at different stages in the
phone okay so when I say funnel customer
lifecycle so we have awareness
consideration purchase retention and
advocacy okay so let's talk about each
one of these parts of the funnel or
customer lifecycle if you will so let's
start with awareness at the very top so
email marketing allows customers to
recognize their problems after which you
can educate them on how your brand can
solve them okay just like any other
marketing channel somebody's looking for
something in need of something we can
come to the rescue in this case we're
gonna come to the rescue
with email and we can go ahead and
educate them on what their need is and
how we can collaborate with them help
them educate them solve their problems
with our product okay so that's what
emails going today we're gonna
communicate with them via email and
we're gonna bring awareness to the
problem by solving the problem that's
what email is good for okay good for
generating awareness for our brand for
example we can share a newsletter with
our customers so we're running a
cosmetics company we can basically
educate them on the five important skin
care products that everyone should have
okay so we can get them to click on the
call-to-action to learn more so
somebody's having some skin care
issues or not sure what products to buy
you know an email can cover that okay
the next step in the customer lifecycle
is consideration so customers focused on
searching for relevant products and
compares the products with similar ones
okay so they're definitely looking there
a little further in the process they're
educated they know what they're looking
for so we can really hit them with the
right email we can send a relevant email
to promote our product okay discover
that perfect moisturizer for your skin
and perfect skin moisturizer smooth
hydrates and contains SPF 20 so we got
the perfect product for that person
who's further along the funnel and
really is ready to purchase that product
so we can hit that person up with the
perfect messaging to talk about purchase
the next step in the lifecycle well
purchase well with purchase we can send
an email that encourages that customer
purchase our product by offering them
something okay by giving an offer for
example we can give a discount discounts
always tend to work so that moisturizer
that that particular customer was
considering buying well they can move
from consideration to purchasing because
we're gonna offer them a discount they
can't refuse yeah so you know it could
beat for a specific date okay it could
be you know something that's going to
get them excited to buy the product 20%
off a moisturizers pretty good deal and
especially if that percentage off is
better than the other products that were
considering buying so getting somebody
that extra incentive to purchase the
product goes a long way via email okay
we want to take that next step in the
lifecycle and nurture our relationship
with customers to ensure they're loyal
okay if they've already purchased how do
we get them purchase again that's
retention we want to retain our
customers we want to get them back to
buy the same product or similar products
or completely different products in
inventory so what do we do we're gonna
send an email we're gonna see in the
email to active customers okay we're
gonna give them an offer just for them
exclusively just for the
in this example we're gonna give them a
combo pack a facial kit at just $39 and
get a sunscreen worth $10 for free so
you can come up with all sorts of
different combinations on offers he is
the offer is exclusively just for those
who you want to target and retain as
customers because if you just get
somebody to purchase once it's not going
to work those people have already taken
the that step in the relationship where
they trust your product they purchase
your product now you want to go ahead
and treat that customer special by
giving them an exclusive offer then what
we want to do is advocacy last step in
that customer lifestyle we want to
convert that active customer into brand
advocates okay we want that customer to
talk about our brand for us we want them
to promote it and talk about it with
your friends so for example we want to
send an email to those customers to
promote our products okay so for example
we could say hey the sales of our
products for this particular day or for
this month is going to go to our
favorite nonprofit could be educating
poor children or cleaning up plastic in
the ocean or saving animals we want to
be able to get them to speak on our
behalf and say look guys this is a
really good company you know they're
offering me products exclusively they've
offered me discounts in the past they
have good products they have a lot of
different products and on top of all
that they help they help the environment
they help the needy okay they care and
so we can go ahead and provide a call to
action for these customers that are
loyal to our brand and have them share
the email with their friends to spread
the word on you know what we're trying
to accomplish for our nonprofit or if
anything just get them to promote it
maybe give them a discount for every
friend that they get to buy our product
okay it doesn't have to necessarily be
you know just sharing with friends it
can be that extra incentive a giving
them a discount if they do share with
friends and their friends bye okay so
this is the customer lifecycle and
examples of different emails that you
can use at every step along the way in
the lifecycle so let's talk about email
marketing setup so email marketing setup
we have a series of steps that we need
to go through in order to get our email
setup to go ahead and send out to our
target audience and that first step is
we want to identify that target audience
and create segments so if you've taken
some of my and listened to some of my
webinars in the past about Google
Analytics about Google Ads
we talked about segmenting so it's about
targeting a specific audience that's
what segmenting is taking a piece of the
whole so we don't want to email all
users on our list all customers maybe we
want to target a specific segment okay
so we want to be able to identify that
segment who is that segment is it
somebody who or a group of people or you
know a partial list of our customers who
purchase a specific product I would say
so
versus say our entire list of customers
because our entire list of customers can
purchase a number of different products
and so by targeting a specific segment
of our audience or our customer base we
can hone in on the message so if they
all have something in common like they
all bought that moisturizer then we can
go ahead and be specific with our
messaging then we want to create
campaigns and set an appropriate
call-to-action okay so what is it that
we want to say to these these people
this segment of users then once you
create that campaign and and set up the
messaging and call to action we want to
test the email before we actually click
send this is a very important step test
that email before we sent and then when
we send the campaigns immediately or we
can schedule a time so my advice here is
always schedule a time you want to be
able to figure out the best time to send
that email and then once the email sent
whenever that is you want to be able to
analyze performance and there are some
key metrics now you want to hone in on
when we talk about email
Marketing and some of those are open
rates click-through rates
okay response rate okay so we want to be
able to hone in on certain key metrics
when it comes to emails so here's what
we need to do create our list I had
contact store list create our campaign
okay we want to select the list choose a
format modify the template and then send
the email campaign so these are some
basic checklist that you want to do so
let me give you an example and go to
MailChimp so if I'm in MailChimp
basically I'm gonna create a campaign
okay so it's an email that I'm going to
work with and you can see with MailChimp
I have some some examples here regular
automated plain text or a/b test I want
to do a regular email I'm just gonna
call it test and then I'm gonna click
begin okay so we want to add our
recipients who are we gonna have so
we're gonna choose our audience okay so
we're just gonna choose a sample test
for now okay we can personalize the to
field if we want okay so what do we want
to do we want to call people by their
first name their last name the first and
last name where we can customize it just
go with first name to keep it a little
bit personal yeah then we have the
subject line here so it's all about
messaging right so whoever we're
targeting we want to be able to add a
message so we're just gonna say and and
subject line is very key here so you
want to have a subject line that's
really going to resonate with your
audience so whoever that segment
audience is we want to make sure that
the subject line is going to resonate
with with them so that they can open up
that email okay so we'll just say have
any good day we can make it better just
as an example something that's gonna be
attention-grabbing if you will you'd
always tweak the subject line in fact my
advice is always do a/b testing on the
subject line so you can do two different
subject lines with one email to figure
out which one has better open rates and
then with MailChimp we can go ahead and
design the content of our email so we're
gonna click design email okay we can
select a template we have
save templates already okay or we can go
with a theme so MailChimp has a lot of
good offers now there's a lot of
different email platforms out there I
particularly like MailChimp because of
this very feature they have a lot of
good themes here a lot of different
layouts that you can use okay so you
know we're going to showcase that
product okay and that's the template
we're gonna use here so here we go we're
gonna showcase our product we're gonna
add that photo of our product here and
we're gonna go ahead and put some nice
messaging in here with some nice
call-to-action we can put our logo up
here for branding again we can edit the
content here so based on that segmented
list in this example for Linda's company
maybe she wants to target those folks
who bought her moisturizer before her
face moisturizer and she wants to
retarget them she wants to go ahead and
say hey you guys have bought my product
before check out this new face
moisturizer that we have to offer so
whatever the case is you want to be able
to plan that out ahead of time you want
to be able to plan out who your audience
is you want to plan out your messaging
and you want to go ahead and set up the
messaging based on that audience so once
you have the messaging in place
well while you're more or less ready to
go okay so once you get the content all
set up you could schedule that campaign
okay and you can also add a social post
to your campaign so we can share that
information on social so email
integrates nicely with social media so
again that's that's pretty much what you
need to do here you need to really think
about who it is you want to target
choose those recipients okay customize
it and make it personal create a good
subject line in fact create two subject
lines and then align that content with
that audience okay that's that's really
the checklist here so again we look at
this checklist creating our list who do
we want to send the email to so we added
our contacts to the list we set up the
campaign we selected the list we chose
the format we modified it
with a good subject line with some good
messaging and then we're gonna schedule
that email campaign so that's the
checklist to go off okay so remember
identify target audience and create
segments then you create that campaign
and in our case we did set an
appropriate call to action you know get
shopping basically we want people to
shop our new moisturizer key thing here
is before we send it out we want to test
that email once everything looks good
we're going to I would advise schedule
it but you can always send the email
when you're ready
I would schedule it at the appropriate
time and day okay so in this case you
don't want to send an email out on a
Friday afternoon okay when people are
getting ready for the weekend you
certainly don't want to send an email
out over the weekend because you're not
gonna have many people look and open it
and you probably don't want to send the
email out on a Monday morning when most
people are getting into the office from
a long weekend and catching up on emails
so from my experience you know Tuesday
Wednesday depending on your time zone I
would always say you know late morning
or early afternoon tends to be a good
time but that's why we have performance
that's why we can analyze performance we
want to be able to see what the open
rates are on the click-through rates are
so that we can make adjustments for
future emails so let's talk about some
of those metrics and when you do send
that email you know we're gonna look at
that open right so open rate is the
percentage of the total number of
recipients who open an email so okay so
if we basically you know sent it to X
amount of people - those emails that are
bounced so let's just say you know we
sent it to 102 people okay for
simplicity sake two of those emails
bounced okay so that means that we've
had a hundred net 100 emails that
receive the email and let's just say 75
open the email okay we wrote such a good
subject line that they opened it okay
that's 75 percent that's a 75% open
that's how you measure
right click-through rate okay so if they
open it we hope that they click on
something and so for all of those emails
that were delivered okay in this case a
hundred how many actually did click on
our call to action so let's just say
seventy-five opened it out of the
hundred that's a seventy-five percent
open rate but of the hundred that
actually were delivered let's just say
we had 25 that actually clicked on the
call to action and so that's 25 percent
okay and so you want to be able to
measure not only who opens it but who
clicks on the call to action so that's
click-through rate for email marketing
and then response rate so it's the
percentage of the total recipients who
clicked on a link of your email campaign
and actually completed the action so in
our example we're trying to get people
to click on the shopping call to action
and get them to purchase so we sent 100
emails and out of the 25 who actually
clicked we add 10 who actually took
action and purchase so 10 divided by a
100 is 10% so you have open rate
click-through rate and response rate
those are some key metrics for email
marketing okay the first step is you got
to get people to open it that's where
the subject line is so important
click there wait that's where the
messaging and call-to-action is so
important we want to get people to click
on that call to action and then the
response rate we want them to buy so
those are our three key metrics related
to email marketing so let's take a look
at an example if we go back to our email
marketing platform MailChimp in this
example we're gonna take a look at some
reports so most email marketing
platforms have reporting functionality
built in and so in this case what we
want to do is we want to be able to take
a look at the open ranked click-through
rates of the emails that have been sent
out previously so here we could see our
April email coupon versus Tolle's promo
okay so we've had basically you know
opens and clicks so 14 percent open rate
1.4 percent click-through rate so the
March email that went out did a little
bit better 19
open two and a half percent on the
click-through rate so here we could see
how many people actually were sent how
many open it and how many clicks so this
is MailChimp makes it very easy for us
to measure you know open and click rates
and then we can measure by revenue as
well based on the campaign so that's
measuring the response rate so it's all
built in so most email marketing
platforms have open right and click rate
already built into the functionality so
you can measure those two metrics
against any email so let's talk about
the benefits of email marketing so what
are some of the benefits well we've
already mentioned to Linda that it's
cost effective it's time saving
real-time marketing less intrusive
builds credibility increases visibility
and brand awareness and it's an easy way
to track ROI these are all the benefits
for email marketing and we're gonna go
talk about some of these now
so basically when we talk about cost
effective you know some email marketing
platforms charge based on the number of
users who you send the email to time
saving well you saw how quick it took me
to set up that email campaign the key is
figuring out who you want to send it to
and we talked about real-time marketing
you know we're sending this email out
basically in real time trying to meet
our customers needs
at the right time it's less intrusive
because we can customize the emails okay
we can as you saw I can put first name
in there to make it more personal so
when something is more personal it's
less intrusive especially if it's a
segment that he knows your brand ok
builds credibility a we gain credibility
when we offer exclusive offers to repeat
customers or you know try and build
advocacy by working with nonprofits ok
and increases visibility and brand
awareness why because you know we could
send our email out to a large group of
people and that's a good way to generate
brand awareness and as you saw we can
easily measure
not only open rates click rates but ROI
so how many people from that email went
on and purchased so we can measure that
it's very easy to measure email so let's
move into a be testing so a/b testing is
key to email marketing okay so any email
marketing gaining high open rates and
click through rates will result in more
website visitors and sales okay in
theory that's what's supposed to happen
we get more opens we get more people to
click we get more people to click we're
gonna get more people to purchase okay
but it's not as easy as it sounds so how
do we make that possible well we're
gonna do that via a/b testing I've
already mentioned it when I setup my
example campaign in MailChimp I stressed
and stressed and stressed that we need
to have 2 subject lines go out per email
okay so before I stress that again let
me just reiterate what AV testing is an
a/b testing is a method to analyze which
of the two email campaign strategies
most effective in terms of high open
rates and click rates okay so in this
case an a/b testing you can send out two
emails you can send out two subject
lines you can send out two call to
actions you're just really what you're
doing is you're testing one against the
other
that's what a/b testing is and so in my
example I talked about that subject line
so for better results a B testing can be
done with the subject line can also be
done with the email content so the
subject line impacts the open rate okay
so I wrote a subject line I don't even
know how that subject line is gonna
perform but if I write a second subject
line then I'll be able to basically give
myself a better chance of getting a
better open rate because I'm offering up
two different subject lines
likewise for email content so the
subject line and email content are the
most important elements so we want to be
able to test them if they're interesting
intriguing attention-grabbing
then it's gonna in the case of subject
lines a result in open rates if the
content itself is interesting engaging a
good offer good call to action then the
click rates are going to be
increased so we want to be able to serve
up variations for our audience so we
want to consider an example of an a/b
test where Linda has set up two
variations of the email campaign as an
example so she's gonna send two
different subject lines to test which
one generates more open rates because
that's what subject line a be testing is
gonna do one of them is gonna have a
higher open rate okay
so in our example here Linda sends
version a of the email to 50% of the
recipients with the subject line three
important strategies to increase your
open rate well version B which is sent
to the other 50% has the subject line
three important strategies to increase
your open rate so the only difference
here is three and three the number three
spelled out well because she sent out
two different subject lines she's gonna
now be able to measure the success of
that a/b test and it just so happens
version a has a higher open rate numbers
always tend to work in subject lines by
the way so Linda sends version a of the
email to 50 percent of the recipients 80
dollars today but ninety dollars
tomorrow and version B to the remaining
50 percent eighty dollars today ninety
dollars tomorrow and the only really
succinct difference here is using the
word but versus a comma and she sent
that email out and that email went out
and the data's coming in and she's gonna
measure the success of that eighty test
well version B has the higher open rate
you know we want to be short succinct
and stay away from those conjugations
like but it tends to have a negative
connotation so the shorter more direct
email or subject line eighty dollars
today 90 tomorrow not so passive more
direct and that tend to have the higher
open rate so you always want to test
those subject lines to generate high
open rates another example here
version a again gets 50 percent with the
subject line uh-oh your prescription is
expiring version B your prescription is
expiring
you folks listen to this webinar right
now I wonder which one you think will
perform go ahead and put your comments
right below this video I'm curious what
version of the subject line you would
open so let's go ahead and measure the
success of the a/b test she sent the
email out to different subject lines 50%
got one subject line the other 50% got
the other subject line and it just so
happens version a uh-oh your
prescription is expiring there's a
little bit of a you know personalization
to that you know for me your
prescription is expiring seems to be a
little bit more you know command ish hey
your ascriptions expired so we expect
you to purchase where you have a little
uh Oh in front it's like hey you know I
think your prescriptions expiring maybe
you should think about renewing it okay
I think that's how that's interpreted at
least that's how I interpret it so I
would probably go ahead and click on
that email and with that subject line so
you could see subtle differences in the
subject lines make a big difference in
open rates so in order to keep improving
those open rates you need to continue
and not continue should always do
subject line testing always because one
subject line is always gonna have a
better open rate than the other so
always do a/b testing when it comes to
subject lines and email content for that
matter okay so we're always going to do
continuous a/b testing so with
continuous a/b testing we can test very
various elements of the email case so
you can always test the sender's name
the subject line the copy that call to
action the design the imagery there's a
lot of different elements you can test
with emails for example centers name
okay so you want to personalize it as
much as you can okay you don't want to
do a no will reply you want it to come
from a human being in this case Sam okay
at least that's what I think let's see
what the test States no surprise version
a has
I are open right if you customize these
things and personalize them then it goes
a long way sending an email from a no
reply is not a good best practice let's
talk about the subject line again so we
got a webinar increase your email open
rates webinar increase your email open
rates so the webinar is dynamic on
version a okay so we're sending that out
and because it's dynamic that's going to
you know beat out the static webinar
increase your email open rates a lot
more elements we can test here so for
example the email copy so learn some
easy ways to increase your email open
rates join us on May 10th 2009 teen 7:00
p.m. for an interactive discussion with
our experts
well version B is more personalized to
say message but we're actually
addressing someone specific in this case
Rachel so we can measure the success of
the a/b test but it's no surprise that
anything that's customized that comes
from somebody
a name you know--with a dynamic email
subject line is going to perform better
it's gonna increase open rates and it's
gonna increase click rates so we can
also test that call to action the
difference here is coloring save my seat
yellow versus save my seat blue again go
ahead and play along here if you're
watching this go ahead and add a comment
and just see if you're right is you
think it's blue or you think it's yellow
on the call-to-action color does go a
long way in email marketing so let's
measure the success of this a/b test and
it just so happens yellow is going to
perform better why does yellow perform
better than blue what's more positive
plus it it kind of resonates a little
bit stronger and easier okay it stands
out a little bit better it's not as
passed Ali and dull as this shade of
blue we're using so you can see here
we're testing every bit of the elements
of the email anything from the from to
the subject line to
the message to the call-to-action and so
at the end of the day you know you want
to be able to send out the best email
that's gonna give you the best results
so we're gonna send that out the
entirety of the email and we could see
version a looks a lot better and why
does version a look a lot better in this
example because look at the font size is
a little bit bigger version B font size
small are harder to read that's another
thing you can test larger fonts tend to
do a little bit better now you don't
want to go overboard and have them you
know 48 points or 50 points or plus you
know 14 versus 12 goes a long way we can
continue testing we can test imagery you
can see here we have a hand aligned with
the call-to-action they just look
different that's all version a has one
type of hand version B is the other type
of hand aligned with the call-to-action
let's go ahead and send out that test
and see what works well version B works
why the hand stands out a little bit
more clear it doesn't blend in with the
call-to-action so you can see we're
testing different elements here and
we're always improving and adding to
what's working so we started out with a
no reply versus somebody's name then we
move to a subject line then we move to
personalization then we move to you know
call-to-action then we move to an
increase font meaning the design and
then we're out in imagery so we're
constantly improving the email with each
test eventually you're gonna get to a
point where you know the email is gonna
be good and you're gonna just continue
to test different options on it to
continue to increase open rates click
rates and response rates final output
looks like this again that personalized
email response from Sam versus no reply
you know we got a nice dynamic subject
line got a personalized the email to
Rachel with larger font okay we got a
nice call-to-action that stands out with
a nice image to accompany that
so we've tested all these different
elements this is the bad
combination based on everything we test
it so when we get that email to go this
is what its gonna look like in the
future but guess what we're not gonna
stop testing so we can continue to test
those subject lines continue to test the
messaging continue to test the email
design continue to test different call
to actions continue to test different
images you're never going to stop
testing with email marketing
okay so let's switch over to how to
optimize the subject line subject line
is such a key component to email
marketing so as we showed you in the
last segment we tested a subject line
and we used a number the number three
versus three spelled out just so happens
that numbers tend to do a little bit
better they're shorter easier to read
and they resonate better so including
number in your subject line you can
include an emoji in your subject line
you emails come a long way emojis aren't
just social media-based
you can use emojis in subject lines I
highly recommend it you know I just sat
out on an email last month with the
subject line about you know spring
showers bring May flowers and guess what
emoji I had in that subject line a
flower okay may sound cheesy but it goes
a long way so according to Experian
subject lines with emojis can increase
open rates by 45% people resonate with
emojis especially if they're positive
emojis okay so we want to personalize
those subject lines for better open rate
okay I see personalized don't be so
stale remember that subject line we
tested uh-oh he's putting uh-oh in there
made it sound like we actually cared it
was a little bit personal it wasn't so
personal we weren't dressing a specific
person but one little word goes a long
way in a subject line because when
people get emails and they read emails
and a lot of people are inundated with
emails the subject line is what they're
reading first and just by personalizing
it adding a number add an emoji I'm just
making it positive and easier to read
they're likely to open
so personalized email messages can
improve click-through rate and open
rates as well so you want to personalize
your email as much as you can
whether that be from the from field to
putting that person's name in the
salutation so personalize subject lines
have been found to increase open rates
by up to 50 percent so don't come across
as spammy come across as you know who
your audience is and you're talking to
them and then you want to prefer title
case subject lines so title face subject
lines for example when I say title case
Game of Thrones is my favorite show
every initial letter in that title is
capitalized okay you can go with the
sentence case Game of Thrones is my
favorite show it doesn't stand out as
much of course if you go at lowercase it
definitely doesn't stand out it looks a
literate and somebody's probably not
gonna open it so you always go with that
title case the every initial letter gets
capitalized so how to optimize that
subject line well watch the length of
your subject line you want to be
conscious of character counts so 17 to
24 characters you want to keep it short
succinct and to the point but
personalized with an emoji with initial
caps on each word to make it stand out
but you have to do that within Sony 217
and 24 characters so according to
campaign monitor the ideal length of a
subject line is up to 24 characters and
they're more likely to boost those email
rates okay so keep it short
make it impactful make it personalized
like I mentioned before if you get too
long then it may get cut off and it may
not have the same impact as something
shorter so that's why we always
recommend keeping it up to about 24
characters okay if you go over by a
couple characters not the end of the
world but try and stay within that range
develop a sense of urgency okay so when
we say sense of urgency we mean sense of
urgency meaning if that coupons gonna
expire you want to let people know it's
going to expire that day or the next day
within a few days okay so you can use
things like hurry up or limit offer or
limited stock or offer expires on okay
so add a bit of sense of urgency I mean
sky is not falling here but if that
coupons expiring at the end of the week
you probably want to mention something
to the effect of hey offers expiring or
hurry up so let's talk about optimizing
your email content so we focused a lot
on subject lines let's talk about the
email content itself so some ways to
optimize email content are we want to
send the content that is relevant to
customer expectations so content needs
to match that expectation we want to use
bullet points to make the content
readable we want to follow logical
structure we want to use compelling
imagery and for design emails with
responsive designs and what we mean by
responsive design is hey most people are
gonna be checking that email on their
mobile phone okay so make sure when you
design the email it's also going to be
good not just on desktop but on tablet
and mobile as well and then of course
SCO's without saying but avoid
grammatical mistakes go ahead and spell
checked it and that's why we put an
emphasis on testing your email before
you actually send it and when you
actually send an email test email don't
send it to yourself send it to
colleagues you know send it to another
group a fresh set of eyes a fresh set of
issac it's going to be able to pick out
that misspelled word that you overlooked
so I can't stress the sending of the
test email because it's going to be able
to you know in a way ensure that you're
doing everything on this list in
addition to grammatical mistakes you
know the person who's receiving your
test email your colleague at work may be
looking at that email on their mobile
phone and if it doesn't look good to
them they're gonna let you know some
other ways to optimize email content
personalization so we did that on the
a/b testing you always want to
personalize it question is hey do I use
first name do I use first and last name
well guess why you can test
but you want to personalize it okay you
want to choose the right fonts and
colors for your email so when we were
going through some examples on testing
you know I always tend to go a little
bit larger on the font you could play
around with it I don't think you should
probably use white lettering on a black
background that just is not very good or
best practice but go ahead and try it if
you want you can always play around and
test these but you want to choose
something that's really gonna resonate
with the recipient of the email okay you
want to build a rapport with customers
by sharing insights they value for
example the beginning of this webinar we
talked about advocacy we talked about
you know sharing with them some of the
nonprofits that we work with as a
company okay if we have a you know
cosmetics company and we have different
products like moisturizers and facial
creams we mase wanna state that hey we
don't use any animals in the testing of
these products you know we're Pro animal
we're not you know we're not gonna use
animals in the testing of our products
and that probably resonates with a lot
of your customers so you want to bet go
ahead and build a rapport with those
customers by sharing those insights and
use recipient names yeah you always want
to personalize it then add a clear
call-to-action at the end you always
want to have that call-to-action
regardless of what the email is hey it
could be just a simple read more or hey
donate you know it doesn't have to
always be so hardcore in terms of hey
purchase our products I could be a
turn-off especially if you're sending
the emails out once a week to your
customer base they're constantly
hammering them with by now by now by now
they're gonna get turned off so you want
to mix up the call to actions and that
goes back to the very first step and
what kind of email are you gonna send
out and who are you gonna send it to so
you have to align those two but somebody
who doesn't even know who your brand is
you're not going to put a call to action
of by now you're probably gonna say hey
check us out we have some cool stuff for
you okay let's talk about automating
email email automation so triggered
emails are
sent to customers based on an event date
or user behavior okay so when we say an
event could be a special occasion like
Mother's Day okay it could be a date
like a birthday or anniversary or a
specific day of the week can also be
based on user behavior you know a good
example of user behavior are those who
abandon the car you can trigger an email
in fact MailChimp has free marketing
functionality so with MailChimp hey if
somebody abandons our car we can have an
email trigger and we could send an email
a nice email that says hey we noticed
you didn't finish
purchasing our product and I'm not sure
what happened but hey here's another 10%
off or you can always just make product
recommendations as well but you want to
react to user behavior and use emails to
your advantage for that so you want to
take be cognizant of different occasions
you want to be cognizant of special
events holidays etc and user behavior so
these types of emails can be automated
because you know when they might happen
or that they are probably going to
happen so autoresponder emails are sent
at frequent intervals based on the
behavior of subscribers so for example
if somebody purchases something then
you're gonna get an email that probably
says hey thank you for your purchase
another email that says hey your
products on its way and then another
email that says hey your package or
product has been delivered so that's an
example of an auto made-it email that
goes out if somebody purchases your
product you probably want to thank them
for that then you probably want to let
them know that hey it's on its way here
you could track it and then again you
want to confirm it's been delivered but
thank them again so that's an example of
an automated email that goes out okay
let's talk about types of email
campaigns so you have different types of
email campaigns and the first is a
newsletter so with email newsletters
subscribers are connected and informed
about product updates so it doesn't
necessarily have to be a product they
buy it could be a product they subscribe
to like software okay you always want to
be able to send out that newsletter to
let them know what's going on with your
product
are there upcoming product updates ahead
is it one that just happened
is there a webinar that discusses the
new product update so that's what the
newsletter is going to do inform the
end-user about the update so how to
optimize okay so you stock your email
content create a compelling header share
different variety of useful content like
videos articles etc with those
recipients and then follow a consistent
schedule so that's how you handle a
newsletter you should always create a
compelling header but if you're gonna
sign our newsletter make sure you
support it with some good information
like a video that they can go watch or
an article that will follow up on what
you put in the email or promoting that
webinar that's going to talk about that
product update so example here is a
newsletter that gets sent out and here
you can see it talks about business
process it's got some nice imagery in
there okay call to action it's got a
little bit of everything in this email
template okay
and that's when we talk about stack your
email content that's what you talked
about stacking you can see at the top
it's got work with the industry best
subscribe now okay they validate that
with 25 years of taught not service then
they talk about hiring the best talent
and you got the next bit of content
below that so that's stock to email
content okay that's going to be
supported by compelling header and then
they're going to share a variety of
different content in there like there
could be clicks in there too video
videos and articles moving off from
newsletters to promotional emails so we
want to be able to drive revenue by
sending special offers through
promotional email okay so how do we
optimize a promotional email well we
want to personalize the campaign okay
promotional we want to definitely
personalize it include time-sensitive
offers we want to get people to react
okay so that means you know adding a
sense of urgency in the title and the
subject line okay you can send offer
emails on holidays if it's Mother's Day
they sent it a couple days before or
even send it on if it's personalized
then you can say hey so-and-so we know
your mother here take 20% off
that kind of personalize the email with
an offer goes a long way hearing an
example from Tom's limited-time extra
20% off all styles they include the code
in there okay again you can see the the
sensitivity and the a sense of urgency
with the limited time another email
campaign type and personally one of my
favorites is abandoned cart so I'm
banning card emails I like working with
abandoned card emails because you know
we want people to purchase and as much
as you try on your email marketing
campaign a drive traffic to the website
and as hard as the website works to get
people to convert through the shopping
cart it's never gonna be a hundred
percent and so abandon cart emails give
us that extra incentive to get that
person back to the shopping cart to
purchase okay so these emails are shared
with customers who have added product to
their cart but didn't finish through the
checkout process in other words they
didn't purchase the product so it's an
effective way of sales recovery it's it
gives us another opportunity to reach
out to that person who just is almost
there but not quite ready to finish the
purchase so what are we gonna do we're
gonna send out an email for those that
abandon their car and we're gonna use a
simple abandoned cart email template
okay you want to be simple here you
don't want to get complicated we're
trying to make this easy for them to
finish purchasing the products and we
want to definitely personalize it okay
we want to send a series of email
reminders okay in your email reminder
add a product image so it's customized
as it can be it could be even the
product image of what they've abandoned
and that's the best practice so if it's
that facial moisturizer that Linda's
trying to promote and she can't quite
get enough people to finish purchasing
the product there they're banning the
cart well she can certainly send out the
abandoned cart email okay so for example
you want to personalize it hey you
forgot to complete your order you left
something in your car can we help email
too
there so-and-so items in your shopping
cart are selling out quickly it's a
gentle reminder okay so come across a
little bit different here okay email
three hey so-and-so 20% off on your car
valid until so-and-so offer on your
favorite product so the first email that
went out in the series of emails it's
hey you forgot something hey is there
anything we can do to help you complete
the product purchase email to is just
that gentle reminder hey you're selling
out quickly you might want to purchase
that product and the email three is to
really help them along by saying hey
here's twenty percent off valid until
so-and-so so it's just a small series of
emails that go out try and get somebody
back into the shopping cart
okay let's talk about re-engagement
campaign so on a reengagement campaign
it's a series of emails sent to an
active email subscribers so what it does
is a boost engagement and helps to
maintain a high inbox placement ratio
inbox placement ratio so we want to be
able to make sure that we're getting
people back on a subscriber list so how
are we going to optimize for something
like this this is now these are
difficult type of email campaigns we're
trying to reengage with people who are
inactive so we want gamma fication to
re-engage subscribers or we want to
prefer a subject lines like hey we've
been missing you or did we do something
wrong okay we can run a poll or
competition to re-engage with those
subscribers so for example hey we'd hate
to miss your birthday go ahead and
update your account this is a Starbucks
email so we'd hate to miss your birthday
so it's that you know message of missing
you you can always soften or sweeten the
deal with an offer as well so that
brings us to how to engage with new
subscribers so we just talked about rien
gauging with inactive we want to talk
about engaging with new subscribers so
how to engage with new subscribers well
thank your subscribers for joining it
create clear and compelling subject
lines that is a must regardless of what
type of email II sent out you always
want a
that compelling subject line okay we
noticed the good examples within 17 to
24 characters know the ideal time to
message okay again setting it on the
weekends not gonna work okay sending it
out during the weekday you know in the
morning mid-morning you know sometimes
in the afternoon works really depends on
who your audience is
well weekend's probably aren't gonna
work they avoid the no reply Center name
again personalize it
you're either Sam or Rob or so and so
sally you know let them know that the
emails come from a real person okay
because if it doesn't come from a person
most people aren't going to respond okay
we want to let our subscribers know the
privacy policy so we want to let them
know that we abide by a privacy policy
okay that's you know getting you know
straight with people who are new they
don't know your brand they don't know
your privacy policy they don't want to
get spammed in other words so putting
that out there makes you more
transparent and trustworthy and again
personalization always personalized if
it's new if it's in active repeat
customers loyal customers lifetime
customers you should always personalize
and you should always be courteous and
always thank them and then prefer
attractive email designs can work with
something that's going to be I catchy
and then most important most important
is include an unsubscribe link I can't
tell you how annoying it is to get an
email and not have the unsubscribe link
there that makes me want to unsubscribe
even if it was a good email I still look
for that because maybe they're good
company but they're spamming me they're
sending me too many emails so maybe I
want to unsubscribe or change my
subscription so you always want to
include that unsubscribe link in fact in
the United States it's actually law so
there is regulation about that around
that so you need to include an
unsubscribe link it's just common
courtesy if anything though bodes well
ok of course you don't want people to
scribe but you don't want them to get
annoyed either let's talk about email
marketing tools so we talked about
MailChimp so there plenty of email
marketing platforms out there I use
MailChimp I've used a few in the past
like Marketo I've used Ojo vertical
response so there are a lot of different
tools out there here some of them again
MailChimp Marketo Marketo is a marketing
automation tool or system and marquetta
is good for sending those automated
emails HubSpot convertkit send in blue
Aweber I mean these are just some of the
many veteran a so let's show a demo
again of an email marketing campaign so
let's show an example of a newsletter
that one of my clients had sent out and
so this is Paul Ekman group called Ekman
dr.eggman inspired the TV show lie to me
so well known in the industry of
micro-expressions he's the form
mentioned expert in micro-expressions
and he sends out email marketing
campaigns and he sends out a monthly
newsletter so this is a newsletter sent
out in November 2018
and if we look at it you can see here
okay it's stacked content
nice imagery okay respectful
disagreements how to deal with
disagreements this holiday season so
really relevant personalized because and
timely because it was set in November
during the holiday season so I've got
some nice imagery there okay we got
content in here and then right below
that on the stack content what do we
have final hour 24 hours 25% off so that
sense of urgency built in to the email
then here you go you have some other
content in there based on the face of
contempt okay just an example of a
microexpression and then right below
that what do we see we see a call to
action learn how to use
micro-expressions to your advantage so
call to action here then we have some
more information here with the learn
more so a newsletter that went
basically they a blog post built into
the email with some nice content
reminding folks hey they have 24 hours
got some other useful information in the
email so this email went out very timely
98,000 okay see subject line here
controversial respectful disagreements
and Thanksgiving okay
could the subject line be a little
mature yes possibly but if we look at
the open rate 15% 16% open rate okay
industry average in education and
trainings 18 percent okay so they're
close to the industry average on the
click rate you know one point six
percent on the click rate industry
average two point one so we can see what
the top links were clicked okay so they
have a lot of links and MailChimp will
help you measure what links were clicked
the most who subscribed what subscriber
with the most opens we can see opens by
country but that's an example of a
newsletter for this particular company
ok stack content and sense of urgency
and you can see the subject line timely
newsletter so this is a a good I think a
good example of an email for the time of
year okay so let's go over the checklist
again for email marketing so good
reminders on the checklist this is a
checklist you want to make sure all
boxes are checked you want to create
interesting subject lines as they boost
your open rates direct correlation with
open rates is subject line okay you want
to keep your content relevant and
consistent with your brand you want to
check the sender name okay so you want
to make sure not only to personalize but
the name of lines of the email address
case you'd always personalize always
personalize the subject line and the
email copy text meaning you know don't
just say hello say hello to Sally P Robb
Michael etc always include an
unsubscribe link in emails
okay give people the option to
unsubscribe okay you can always read
gage them another way or later on but
you don't want to urge anyone of your
potential customers use a/b testing we
talked about a/b testing the webinar
there's lots of different elements we
can test from subject line to content to
font call-to-action to imagery to
subject line etc there's no shortage of
elements in an email you can test you
want to use welcome emails to build good
customer relationships so when somebody
signs up for a newsletter send out a
welcome news email to them hey welcome
thank you for signing up
you should always segment your list
based on user behavior so you have a
group of people who purchase product a
customize your email for product day but
you know you can mention product B and C
in there but know who your audience is
so you can talk to your audience and you
can always ask your subscribers to
update their preferences as well because
you want to make sure you're sending out
emails to the right person right address
okay so this is a short checklist now we
can expand upon this but these are some
of the most of the key items when it
comes to email marketing some other
items on the checklist include features
such as countdown timers and live polls
okay make it interactive okay choose the
right email frequency don't be sending
emails three or four times a week you
know once a week is probably as much as
you want to go pending on what it is if
somebody purchases something then you
probably want to send an email thanking
them for the purchase another one
letting you know the product has been
shipped and another one with thank you
the product has been received reward
those subscribers send out exclusive
offers okay make sure your emails are
optimized for mobile that means send out
test emails and check it on different
devices create a schedule okay you can
automate these emails so create a
schedule that makes the most sense have
a footer and header in the email and in
that footer and header is gonna be some
information okay just like I showed you
with the micros prescience there was a
footer and header avoid spam fell
ders okay how do you avoid spam filters
well apply best practices and don't have
spammy subject lines have an actual name
associated with the reply to email and
and split up your list as well when you
send out one email to 150,000 people it
could probably get caught up in some
spam so segment out your audiences keep
your audience listening can be specific
to the audience that's gonna help avoid
spam and then of course you always want
to measure and analyze results to
remember a lot of these email marketing
platforms have the results built in
especially open rates and click rates so
keep takeaways from today's webinar we
talked about what is email marketing so
email marketing really is an effective
way to really give get a good message
out to a target audience there plenty of
benefits doesn't cost a lot of money to
do email marketing okay you can do it in
real time it doesn't take a lot of time
okay and you can get some more out of it
we also talked about a/b testing it's a
very key component to email marketing if
you're gonna do email marketing at the
very least test those subject lines but
there's so many different elements you
can test we talked about the types of
different email campaigns from
newsletter to promotional dynamic cart
to reengagement re-engaging those
inactive users so each type of email
campaign is gonna contain a different
way to talk to them okay how to engage
with new users okay so we went over a
best practices list for engaging with
new users some of which means and
personalizing and you always use an
attractive email you want to come across
the very first time with the right way
always always always create a clear
compelling subject line if it's a new or
returning recipient you always want a
clear and compelling subject line and
then there's plenty of email marketing
tools you know I showed you MailChimp
MailChimp has some really good features
in it if I go back to MailChimp
just a drive home the point okay so you
you can look at specific look at really
specific data per email it has reporting
built-in it has all these nice little
templates built in so you can create a
template okay you can leverage a
template and there's lots of templates
you can use even have a Content view so
it has a lot of features built into the
platform this is just MailChimp
I mean Marketo and HubSpot and Aweber
and all these other platforms do very
similar things you just have to pick the
one that works for you the best so I
want to thank you for attending today's
webinar on email marketing if you need
any more information please visit simply
learn com if you have anything to add
certainly go ahead and comment below
this video we'd love to get your
comments on the subject and of course
we'll respond accordingly thank you
again and look forward to seeing you in
future webinars
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos Dinard up and get certified
click here